que je propose que nous commençons
donc bonjour à ceux qui sont présents en
présentiel comme on dit suivant la
terminologie
adoptée depuis quelques années et ceux
qui sont en distanciel que je remercie
beaucoup vous êtes venus nombreux pour
cette conférence de presse donc nous
allons faire une
une intervention à devoir avec Madame la
rapporteur Laurence Cohen puisque nous
avons évidemment et que tous nos
collègues du Sénat
étaient particulièrement binôme toutes
les deux tout au long des auditions et
de nos déplacements pour cette
commission d'enquête qui qui a duré
cinq mois
nous voici nous voici donc parvenu au
terme des travaux de la commission
d'enquête du Sénat sur la pénurie de
médicaments et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique les deux objectifs
étaient affichés dans le motif de la
commission d'enquête créée sur
l'initiative du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste et
dont le rapport a été adopté mardi
après-midi
5 mois quasiment jour projon ce sont
écoulés depuis notre première audition
qui a eu lieu le 9 février dernier au
total nous avons procédé à 54 auditions
tendues 119 personnalités dont un nombre
important de ministres puisque nous
étions nous sommes à 8 ministres
auditionnés en fonction ou anciennement
en fonction transmis plus de 70
questionnaires effectués un bon nombre
de déplacements et je cite immédiatement
celui que nous avons fait Amsterdam au
siège de l'Agence européenne du
médicament avec laquelle nous avons pu
engager un dialogue fructueux ou encore
dans un tout autre registre le contrôle
sur pièce et sur place que nous avons
mené à Bercy pour recueillir
nous sont difficultés et j'utilise une
formule euphémisante des éléments précis
sur l'utilisation du crédit d'impôt
recherche par les entreprises
pharmaceutiques et je vous dis dès à
présent nous avons fini par avoir les
éléments utiles même si ça a demandé pas
mal de travail
d'interprétation derrière nous avons
donc beaucoup travaillé avec Madame
Laurence Cohen ma collègue rapporteur
dans un esprit d'écoute mutuel très
constructive ça se fait on se fait
plaisir mais c'est la réalité voir
souriant d'ailleurs un esprit d'écoute
souriant et je remercie toutes celles et
tous ceux qui se sont mobilisés au cours
de ces mois particulièrement chargé je
signale d'ailleurs au passage que la
difficulté de ce travail a tenu non
seulement au caractère particulièrement
vaste de la question que nous avions à
traiter et qui engage un large spectre
de politique publique mais aussi à la
coïncidence de notre calendrier avec
celui de certains travaux
gouvernementaux ça ne vous a pas échappé
puisque nous utilisions ont largement
été régulièrement suivies de
communication publique de de la part de
l'exécutif ce qui montre à quel point
finalement la Commission a été
utile depuis son début je pense bien sûr
à la mission borne sur la régulation et
le financement des produits de santé
installés en janvier dernier qui rendra
ses travaux à la fin du mois par
ailleurs pendant toute la durée nous
avons donc en même temps eu des annonces
durant tout le mois de juin notamment de
la part du gouvernement au moment au
moment même où nous bouclions notre
rapport ce qui a quand même amené une
petite pression probablement
supplémentaire pour travailler plus vite
c'est le cas par exemple de la fameuse
liste des médicaments essentiels publiés
le 13 juin et aussitôt
controversé décrié suivant les
interlocuteurs qui se sont exprimés sur
le sujet de cette liste je crois pouvoir
dire que nos auditions publiques très
suivies et la façon dont nous avons fait
fait vivre ce sujet tout au long du
premier semestre 2023 au sortir d'un
hiver particulièrement rude sur le front
des pénuries de médicaments on fait
office à la fois d'Aiguillon et de
révélateur des limites et des ambiguïtés
de l'action de l'exécutif et aussi des
difficultés particulières à la fois
conjoncturelles et structurelle et pour
un certain nombre de pays plusieurs
années qui concernent cette
problématique nous voici donc au terme
de ce travail de 5 mois dont nous sommes
particulièrement heureuses Laurence
Cohen et moi-même parce que nous sommes
heureuses qu'il est abouti parce que ça
a été un long travail très mobilisateur
mais aussi parce que nous souhaitions
vraiment après la commission qui avait
eu lieu d'informations qui avaient lu à
l'été 2018 du Céa auquel nous avions
participé toutes les deux nous
souhaitions vraiment voir habitués
aboutir plus
profondément ce sujet l'objectif viser
la fin des pénuries de médicaments
étaient susceptible de rassembler toutes
nos familles politiques s'agissant d'un
phénomène qui suscite défiance et
anxiété anxiété chez les patients et les
patients ainsi que chez les
professionnels de santé et à propos
duquel le Sénat a su dans le passé se
montrer pionnier
le rapport qui vous est présenté
aujourd'hui porte la marque de cet
engagement pluraliste il me semble que
nous avons atteint notre objectif en
découanovant la réflexion et l'analyse
qui sont en ce domaine trop souvent mené
en silo et on donna une vision
d'ensemble de cette chaîne de valeur du
médicament au combien complexe que
constate-t-on nous que loin de cette
résorber les tensions
d'approvisionnement et rupture de stocks
se sont multipliées et aggravés
atteignant un niveau inédit en 2022 de
plus de 3700 déclarations de rupture et
de risque de rupture nous étions à 700 à
l'été 2018 celle-ci touche désormais
toutes les classes thérapeutiques sans
exception tous les territoires français
d'ailleurs de nombreux autres pays il y
a là un dysfonctionnement réel profond
et grave de l'approvisionnement de nos
systèmes sanitaires à européens ce sont
autant de pertes de chances de
renchérissement des traitements de temps
perdu pour nos médecins et pharmaciens
déjà fortement mis à l'épreuve par la
covid-19 dans les cas les plus graves
nous avons révélé la mise en place de
contingentements voire d'interdiction de
lancement de nouveaux protocole de
traitement en termes très concret cela
signifie que l'accès aux soins n'est
plus aujourd'hui une évidence pour les
patientes et les patients français en
fonction des circonstances et des
situations concernant la disponibilité
du médicament nous avons évidemment
analysé en profondeur le large éventail
des causes conjoncturelles et
structurelles des tensions
d'approvisionnement la production
pharmaceutique a été une vision victime
majeure de la délocalisation ayant eu
cours ces dernières décennies la part
des médicaments produits sur le
territoire français ne dépasse pas un
tiers de notre consommation de premier
producteurs européens de médicaments la
France est tombée à la cinquième place
actuellement nous savons qui est la
plupart des principes actifs sont
produits hors Europe mais nous avons
aussi appris que de nombreux étapes du
circuit du médicament sont sous-traités
à l'étranger
les chaînes de valeurs du médicament
sont donc plus vulnérables que jamais le
modèle de la production en flux tendue
et la financiarisation du secteur n'y
étant pas étranger
avec un secteur productif appelé
affaibli et une dépense de santé
contrainte la France n'est aujourd'hui
plus une puissance pharmaceutique au
contraire
la capacité de notre pays à négocier ses
prix et sécuriser son
approvisionnementétiole et son poids
diminue face à la montée de la demande
dans les pays asiatiques notamment et en
tout cas la demande sanitaire mondiale
en matière de médicaments a évidemment
cru proportionnellement à la
l'augmentation qualitative des
politiques sanitaires les laboratoires
qui restent implantés en France sur
yandent de plus en plus vers l'export
qui représente la moitié de leur chiffre
d'affaires aujourd'hui non seulement
contre seulement un cinquième en 1990
nous avons aussi mis en évidence la
stratégie de lente éviction des
médicaments matures 70% des médicaments
touchés par les pénuries ou les tensions
c'est des médicaments anciens dont la
rentabilité a diminué au fil des ans et
je parle ici de médicaments dit de
d'usage quotidien comme de certains
anti-cancéreux en dépit de leur
obligation d'assurer l'approvisionnement
du marché les laboratoires se
désintéressent de ces produits matures
au profit des médicaments innovants dont
les prix connaissent une présentation
effrayante on ne sait quel terme
utiliser mais en tout cas on est au-delà
de ce qu'on aurait pu imaginer pour le
coup de ces médicaments le comité
économique des produits de santé chargés
de fixer le prix peut être les prix
peut-être pris en otage devant la menace
d'arrêt de commercialisation de produits
de déremboursement ou de déni d'accès
précoce la conséquence de ces stratégies
commerciales des laboratoires c'est
d'abord la hausse de la dépense de santé
mais c'est surtout la reprogressive de
l'approvisionnement médicament certes
anciens mais jouant souvent un rôle
essentiel dans notre système de santé et
un rôle essentiel pour un certain nombre
de prise en charge thérapeutiques notre
commission d'enquête révèle notamment
que les industriels français envisagent
dans les prochains mois et années
d'abandonner la production de près de
700 médicaments incluant des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur c'est
dire si les conséquences sanitaires
doivent être anticipées et évaluer avant
que tout cela se mette en oeuvre ou en
tout cas à tout le mois pouvoir trouver
des remplacements thérapeutiques qui
soient à la hauteur de la qualité de
prise en charge actuelle je vous
remercie je passe la parole à Madame
Laurence Cohen rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête
merci madame la Présidente bonjour à
toutes et à tous effectivement à l'issue
de nos travaux nous avons dégagé 36
recommandations qui visent d'une part à
lutter en urgence contre les pénuries
lorsqu'elles adviennent et d'autre part
à s'attaquer à leurs causes
structurelles l'hiver 2022 2023 est en
matière de pénurie extrêmement
instructif la triple épidémie de
covid-19 de grippe et de bronchiolite
comme la crise qui a frappé les
médicaments pédiatriques n'ont été
suffisamment anticipées ni par les
industriels qui produisent à flux tendu
et fonde à tort leur prévision sur les
hivers précédents ni par les pouvoirs
publics
le rapport ainsi sur la communication
particulièrement brouillée du ministre
de la santé pendant cette période pour
mieux préparer les prochaines saisons
hivernales nous invitons le gouvernement
à contrôler davantage les anticipations
des industriels ainsi que la fiabilité
des informations qu'il diffuse surtout
il faut désormais développer des efforts
d'anticipation et de cartographies et
prioriser les molécules les plus
indispensables à la prise en charge des
patientes et des patients la publication
le mois dernier d'une liste de
médicaments essentiels dressés par des
sociétés savantes est une première étape
importante attendue vous le savez tout
et tous de longue date le gouvernement
doit veiller à émettre de l'ordre la
liste cyto publiée a été vivement
critiquée par de nombreuses sociétés
savantes sa méthode d'élaboration est
temps pointée du doigt pour son pour son
opacité vous savez que la Haute Autorité
de santé notamment n'y a pas été
associée et la question des liens
d'intérêt mais tout simplement pas
traité surtout il est crucial que la
question des nouvelles obligations et du
nouveau cadre réglementaire qui sont
destinés à être associés à
l'exploitation d'un médicament dit
essentiel sur le marché français soit
rapidement éclairci sans quoi cette
énième liste n'aura aucun contenu
opérationnel sur ce point également la
commission déplore le faux départ du
ministre de la Santé qui a enchaîné les
déclarations contradictoires ces
dernières semaines il convient en toute
état de cause et c'est un point central
du rapport de donner enfin toutes leurs
efficacité aux obligations qui incombe
aux industriels elles ont certes été
renforcées mais elles font aujourd'hui
l'objet de contrôle extrêmement
insuffisant qu'il s'agisse de plans de
gestion des pénuries ou de l'obligation
de constitution de stocks de sécurité
vous trouverez d'ailleurs dans le
rapport une analyse fouillée des plans
de gestion des pénuries de plusieurs
médicaments essentiels dont le bilan est
inquiétant les contrôles s'avèrent très
lacunaire et n'interviennent que
lorsqu'une tension a déjà été signalée
il faut donc d'urgence combler la totale
disproportion entre l'émission que
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament est censé exercer et les
ressources et moyens qui sont alloués
sans quoi ces pouvoirs de contrôler et
de sanctions resteront inopérant vous
savez on demande toujours plus et mieux
aux agences mais à moyen constant voire
parfois avec des suppressions de poste
au chapitre de l'information sujet
essentielle puisqu'il y va donc capacité
à restaurer la confiance et à apaiser
des situations souvent anxiogènes il
nous est apparu que les dispositifs
actuels étaient encore très perfectible
malgré de réels progrès assez récent je
dois dire il existe quasiment autant de
plateformes de suivi de la disponibilité
des médicaments que de maillon de la
chaîne les données disponibles manquent
d'articulation et d'interopérabilité
mais aussi de fiabilité par ailleurs
faute de coordination entre l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
les agences régionales de santé les ARS
la gestion des signalements de rupture
ne se fait pas à l'échelon locale et les
données agrégées au niveau national
dissimulent de profondes disparités
entre les régions il faut absolument que
l'enjeu de territorialisation fine de la
veille sanitaire soit au cœur du
prochain contrat d'objectifs et de
performance de l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament au chapitre de la
distribution du médicament ensuite les
auditions ont révélé là aussi un certain
désordre une absence de vision
d'ensemble un pilotage aléatoire la
commission plaid pour donner toute sa
portée notamment en situation de tension
au service public de la répartition
matérialisée par les obligations de
services publics des grossistes
répartiteurs ceux-ci sont en effet les
garants de la distribution égale sur
l'ensemble du territoire et à l'ensemble
des pharmacies grandes ou petites de ce
bien universel qui est le médicament
j'insiste sur la notion de bien celle du
médicament le rapport formule par
ailleurs concernant la fabrication
plusieurs propositions pour établir en
urgence la disponibilité de certains
médicaments en situation de pénurie afin
d'exploiter de manière optimale les
capacités de production du marché il
propose d'abord de faciliter le
redéploiement des stocks européens par
l'harmonisation des règles de
conditionnement comme d'étiquetage et la
réorientation de la production de la
production en exigeant des industriels
l'identification de capacités
alternatives de production des
médicaments essentiels en amont des
pénuries il propose également de
favoriser le recours aux préparations
hospitalières comme officinal enfin il
nous paraît indispensable de renforcer
les capacités d'intervention publique en
mettant fin au démantèlement des
capacités de production de
l'établissement pharmaceutique de
l'AP-HP la GEPS je rappelle ici que ces
effectifs s'élèvent à 120 personnes et
que ce sont 40 à 50 ETP qui sont
programmés pour leur suppression il faut
faire évoluer les réglementations car ce
qui est possible en temps de crise doit
l'être à tout moment c'est l'un des
moyens pour que la puissance publique
puisse reprendre la main je vous invite
à regarder dans notre rapport les
multiples expériences qui ont cours en
Europe je pense à la Suisse et au
Pays-Bas mais également dans le monde
l'Egypte le Brésil les États-Unis
le deuxième volet de nos recommandations
vise à s'attaquer aux causes structurel
des pénuries il faut en effet tout faire
pour prévenir purement et simplement
l'apparition des pénuries le rapport
propose ainsi tout d'abord de revoir
profondément les modalités de régulation
des dépenses de médicaments qui ignorent
encore trop aujourd'hui les enjeux
d'approvisionnement les baisses de prix
sur les produits matures comme la
fiscalité du secteur avec la fameuse
clause de sauvegarde ne doivent pas
frapper les médicaments indifféremment
de leur place dans l'arsenal
thérapeutique nous souhaitons qu'il
tienne mieux compte de l'apport médical
et des risques d'approvisionnement et
que lorsque cela s'avère nécessaire les
hausses de prix doivent être facilités
mais en regardant tous ces éléments bien
évidemment concernant la demande des
médicaments nous proposons d'actionner
le levier de la commande hospitalière il
est urgent de placer le critère de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement au cœur des
pratiques d'achat hospitalier qui parce
qu'ils engagent des volumes
considérables peuvent ils doivent être
le bras armé d'une reconquête de la
souveraineté sanitaire il faut donc
définitivement préférer la promotion
d'un agent d'un achat sécurisé et
souverain au seul critère de
l'efficience économique en promouvant
également la qualité environnementale et
sociale puissant levier quoi qu’un
direct de souveraineté et en
généralisant l'usage des clauses
d'implantation européenne sur les sujets
critiques toujours sur le terrain de la
demande la question des volumes de
consommation et de l'encadrement des
prescriptions est apparu central dans la
réflexion du gouvernement sur la
régulation des produits de santé si la
promotion du bon usage est évidemment
une nécessité de santé publique il nous
a semblé qu'en matière d'éducation à la
santé il faut préférer la qualité du
temps médical disponible et la lutte
contre les déserts sanitaires à la
culpabilisation des professionnels cette
petite musique vous savez les médecins
finalement prescrivent trop c'est assez
facile c'est culpabilisateur et ça remet
en cause la formation des médecins donc
avec la Présidente nous appelons à être
très vigilant parce que c'est facile ça
coûte pas cher à l'État et ça ne réglera
rien par ailleurs on ne pourra lutter
efficacement contre les causes profondes
des pénuries sans réponse européenne nos
marchés du médicament sont
interconnectés nous industries aussi il
est indispensable de coordonner nos
efforts plutôt que d'entrer en
compétition nous formulons donc
plusieurs recommandations visant à
ancrer une production européenne durable
de médicaments notamment grâce à nos
atouts en matière sociale et
environnementale
notre commission dessine un bilan pour
le bois mitigé des nombreuses aides à la
relocalisation mise en avant dans le
plan de relance et le plan France 2030
en réalité ces aides ont été distribuées
avant l'établissement d'une stratégie
cohérente de relocalisation sur la
centaine de projets financiers seuls 18
concernait une réelle relocalisation et
seul 5 portait sur un médicament ou
principe actif stratégique de plus le
gouvernement ne peut pas appeler à juste
titre à la relocalisation et laisser
fermer des unités de production je pense
notamment à Sanofi qui en avril dernier
a annoncé 135 suppressions de poche
d'ici 2025 sur les sites d'Aramon et
Sisteron l'équivalent d'une perte de
production de 50 tonnes de principes
actifs selon les syndicats nous appelons
à fixer des conditions plus claires au
bénéfice des nombreuses aides publiques
en faveur de l'industrie pharmaceutique
par exemple le service rend des 710
millions d'euros de crédit impôt
recherche perçus chaque année par
l'industrie pharmaceutique et contestée
c'est à dire que l'état donne 710
millions mais qu'est-ce qui est retourné
par les industries pharmaceutiques nous
faisons le constat d'être public dirigé
fortement vers l'innovation sans qu'elle
ne se traduise par des engagements à
produire en France alors que ceci est
une source d'attractivité incontestable
pour l'industrie de la pharmacie nous
avons aussi mis en évidence des
techniques d'optimisation du cire qui
nuisent à l'approvisionnement de notre
marché en médicaments il nous a fallu
aller chercher ces informations avec
grande difficulté et c'est un euphémisme
auprès du ministère de l'économie et des
finances beaucoup d'opiniâtretés et
merci à toute l'équipe pour les relances
multiples et les quelques menaces qu'on
a pu aussi infliger pour enfin avoir des
informations et puis après il fallait
décoder tout ça enfin le rapport se
penche sur le pilotage de ces polit il
dresse à ce sujet un constat alarmant
entre agence et direction centrales les
politiques du médicament apparaissent
dispersés sans cohérence d'ensemble et
parfois contradictoires c'est pourquoi
nous suggérons la création d'un
secrétariat général aux médicaments
placés sous l'autorité de la première
ministre et chargée de coordonner
l'action des services comme d'arbitrer
entre les différents enjeux sous-jacents
il pourrait donc piloter la réponse aux
pénuries les plus graves et mobiliser au
besoin une force publique d'action
rapide avec l'aide de la Pharmacie
centrale de la PHP des pharmacies à
usage intérieur hospitalières et de
santé publique France en un mot il nous
a semblé qu'il y avait pas de pilote
dans l'avion et qu'il fallait donc faire
une proposition à ce niveau là au niveau
européen une dynamique a vu le jour à la
faveur de la pandémie de covid-19 tout
en mesurant que la santé n'est qu'une
compétence d'appui de l'Union européenne
il faudra la confirmer la soutenir à
l'occasion de l'examen du paquet
pharmace
et d'un éventuel critical béducine actes
nous appelons à lever les nombreux
obstacles qui continuent de faire
barrage à une plus grande coordination
des efforts au niveau européen en
conclusion nous pensons que la réponse
aux pénuries de médicaments est avant
tout une réponse politique et qu'il n'y
a pas de fatalité face au choix des
industriels du médicament qui remettent
en cause l'accès aux soins dans notre
pays cet ensemble de 36 recommandations
constituent un consensus que nous avons
pu dégager avec la présidente Sonia de
la pauvreté entre tous les groupes
politiques du Sénat et je veux
d'ailleurs saluer le travail que nous
avons fait alors c'est un peu de
l'auto-satisfaction mais un binôme au
Sénat c'est important et je pense que on
a réussi y compris à faire en sorte que
toutes les sensibilités et les familles
politiques du Sénat se retrouvent sur ce
rapport qui vous en conviendrait quand
même très critique avec des propositions
qui sont évidemment de nature à modifier
la donne donc c'est 36 recommandations
sont un point d'équilibre sur lequel
nous pouvons tout et tous nous retrouver
et que j'espère le gouvernement prendra
en compte pour arrêter cette spirale
infernale des pénuries et rétablir les
conditions d'une prise en charge
optimale de la santé des Françaises et
des Français et je voudrais dire que
nous allons poursuivre notre travail
avec opiniâtreté avec Sonia puisque nous
allons dès après cette conférence de
presse demandez un rendez-vous au
ministre de la santé et au ministre de
l'Industrie pour voir avec eux quel
recommandation ils vont pouvoir mettre
rapidement en œuvre s'il les partage
mais on va essayer de leur prouver tout
le bien-fondé de nos recommandations
pour qu'il les partages et qu'il les
mettent en œuvre je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la rapporteur donc
je vais vous laisser place aux questions
désormais donc
voilà
par ordre de de demande et d'expression
et à leur indice ton ciel je vais
laisser
d'accord donc madame je vous présenter
et vous présenter votre
je voudrais savoir sur la politique de
régulation des prix du médicament vous
expliquer qu'il faut faciliter des
hausses de prix au global est-ce que ça
veut dire qui faut mettre qu'il faut
augmenter la dépense publique sur le
médicament comment vous voyez les choses
évoluer
on va prendre plusieurs questions trois
questions une première série de trois
questions
oui
bonjour Raphaël Moreau agence de presse
médicale deux petites questions on a vu
en suivant les auditions que vous avez
eu beaucoup de mal à obtenir certaines
informations vous avez répété plusieurs
fois vouloir des réponses précises à des
questions précises vous avez pointé le
souci de transparence une question sur
ce sujet là pourquoi y a-t-il selon vous
un problème de transparence dans le
domaine de la santé et comment vous
l'expliquez voilà le deuxième question
elle est sur la régulation des prix le
CEPS a aussi fait l'objet de nombreuses
discussions est-ce que vous pensez pas
que le CEPS est aujourd'hui bloqué dans
le cadre généralique juridique qui lui
est imposé en prenant en compte
principalement la valeur thérapeutique
du médicament évalue par la HS merci
bonjour Alexandre fache de Luma vous
avez évoqué rapidement le fait que les
industriels projetaient d'abandonner 700
médicaments dont certains intérêts
majeurs est-ce que vous pouvez donner
des exemples sur ces médicaments
intérêts majeurs qui vont être
abandonnés dans les années qui viennent
oui ça sera la on va répondre allez-y
oui bonjour Louis guarineau pour le
bulletin des transports et de la
logistique une question sur le crédit
d'impôt recherche vous avez dit que les
lunettes de 710 millions d'euros étaient
octroyés à l'industrie pharmaceutique
est-ce que vous avez une idée des
contreparties qui pourraient être
demandées à la filière pour au regard de
la recherche et développement et une
deuxième petite question qui est plus
transversale sur le plan de gestion des
pénuries et les stocks de sécurité là
aussi qu'elle serait dans vos
recommandations
les contrôles qui seraient demandés en
termes de pouvoir de sanction
merci
donc la régulation on va essayer de
répondre au binôme comme on a toujours
fait
pour la régulation des prix et les
hausses de prix en réalité le sujet
c'est d'abord un on met en évidence dans
le rapport que l'on dame qui
[Musique]
propose une enveloppe dites médicaments
dans le cadre du projet loi de finances
de la sécurité sociale
et pas forcément estimer à la hauteur
des besoins thérapeutiques et des
besoins sanitaires ça c'est le premier
sujet mais avant de traiter cette
question on voit bien qu'il y a une
évolution de la dépense en matière de
médicaments avec un effet de ciseaux
majeur puisqu'il y a une envolée de de
la prise en charge des médicaments
innovants
avec en contrepartie donc cette
diminution
comptant sur l'effet volume quelque part
drastique du prix des médicaments
matures avec pour un certain nombre des
itérations à de baisse de prix pour par
exemple
les inhibiteurs de la pompe certains
inhibiteurs de la pompe à protons par
exemple utiliser en gastro-entérologie
une baisse à cette année consécutive
pour pourvoir dans l'enveloppe traiter
la question avec
finalement tout un tas d'éléments de
régulation pour essayer d'obliger au
bout du compte à ce que on rentre dans
le dans le cadre budgétaire en réalité
ce cadre budgétaire n'est pas
complètement strictement un objectif
sanitaire en témoigne le fait que
derrière une des conséquences parmi
c'est une des conséquences parmi
d'autres des pénuries c'est une des
causes parmi d'autres des pénuries et
donc cette question de de voilà du PLFSS
se pose et de l'ONDAM très clairement
puisque la population vieillit que les
défenses de santé manifestement ne vont
pas être en diminution en diagnostic
mieux on traite depuis longtemps les
médicaments innovants évidemment doivent
doivent arriver aussi être mise à
disposition d'un certain nombre de
prises en charge stéréotypiques en plus
on arrive à une prise en charge presque
à la personne et à la maladie de la
personne donc ça ça nécessite aussi une
plus grande démultiplications de de la
prise en charge thérapeutique et un
ajustement de la prise en charge
thérapeutique et donc ça tout ça fait
que dans le cadre du du du
CEPS et de la régulation des prix et
bien on voit bien qu'on arrive à un
moment où la logique n'est plus
sanitaire de façon majoritaire et donc
c'est vraiment ce sujet qui se pose et
donc c'est ce que nous avons souhaité
mettre en évidence dans dans notre dans
notre rapport avec un renforcement des
moyens du CEPS pour pouvoir discuter
mais aussi un renforcement de la
présence sanitaire au sein du CE puisque
quand on a regardé la condition la
constitution du CEPS en réalité et bien
la part du sanitaire et de ceux qui
travaillent au sein de la négociation et
comment dire plutôt mince puisque ce
sont plutôt
les objectifs budgétaires et financiers
qui sont présents au travers de la CNAM
par exemple et au travers de des
représentants de des différents
ministères donc voilà c'est vraiment ce
sujet là qui qui
est important et donc je voilà je te
laisse continuer sur la suite
oui
en complément donc effectivement d'abord
il y a il y a tout ce qu'il y a
développé
Sonia sur l'ONDA après on peut aussi
vous savez s'interroger sur cette ondame
d'une manière globale effectivement ici
la dame est votée par la majorité
sénatoriale mais c'est pas tout le monde
j'ai dit non la majorité sénatoriale
mais tout le monde ne le vote pas voilà
et nous ne le votons pas celles et ceux
qui ne votent pas c'est parce que nous
le considérons d'une manière globale
insuffisant alors effectivement aussi au
niveau au niveau des des médicaments
puis il y a une hypocrisie c'est-à-dire
c'est les vases communicants
c'est-à-dire que en fait on pompe sur
les sur les médicaments pardonnez-moi
l'expression un peu familière mature
pour aller sur l'enveloppe des des
médicaments innovants donc vous voyez là
il y a quelque chose qui qui ne peut pas
perdurer ensuite aussi je pense qu'il
faut insister parce qu'il faut faire
attention
nous on dit éventuellement une
augmentation des prix mais attention
c'est il y a vraiment beaucoup de
conditions à cette augmentation des prix
parce que effectivement le LEM c'est ce
qui nous ils nous ont rabâché à longueur
d'audition ça serait uniquement par
rapport au prix qui sont extrêmement bas
en France il faut il faut démonter cet
argument pourquoi il faut démonter cet
argument parce qu'il est faux il est
faux parce que si c'était si c'était la
condition ce serait facile et ce qui se
passe dans les autres pays parce qu'en
Suisse les prix sont plus élevés où en
Allemagne et il y a les mêmes pénuries
donc d'abord les pénuries sont
multifactorielles et donc c'est pour ça
que nous disons que effectivement on
peut revisiter un certain nombre de prix
de médicaments mais sous conditions et
je pense et la j'attire votre attention
nous ne l'avons pas dit ni la présidente
ni moi-même mais c'est très fort dans
notre dans notre rapport il faut faire
une différence entre les grands labos
Big Pharma et les on n'est pas dans le
même monde mais on a bien vu que les
revendications des voies de Big Pharma
sont assez hallucinantes par rapport aux
demandes de hausse de prix donc ça ce
sont mes premières remarques il faut une
grande transparence le problème c'est
que aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
transparence le CEPS
mène un combat courageux
pour essayer d'avoir un contre-pouvoir
vis-à-vis des des labos quand ils
demandent des prix sur tel ou tel
médicament mais nous ne savons pas
comment ça se passe nous n'avons aucun
élément de transparence au niveau au
niveau des prix et non seulement nous
demandons cette transparence mais comme
ça a été souligné nous demandons aussi
qu'on réfléchissent à la composition du
CEPS il faut faire rentrer d'autres
membres dans le CEPS qui sont en lien
avec effectivement tout ce qui est santé
publique mais pas du côté économique du
côté de des des soignants des usagers
etc c'est une question de démocratie
parmi vous m'avez vous nous avez demandé
les 700 médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeurs qui qui serait
abandonné en fait c'est une information
que nous ont donné les industriels
eux-mêmes mais nous n'avons pas eu
d'exemples précis sur ces médicaments
qui seraient qui seraient abandonnés
qu'est-ce que j'ai pas dit ah oui j'ai
pas parlé des des pouvoirs de sanction
aujourd'hui
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament mène un travail extrêmement
important
mais ils sont très absorbés justement
par la gestion des pénuries tant c'est
un phénomène qui a été
exponentielle ces derniers temps et ils
n'ont pas suffisamment de moyens pour
mener les contrôles
en termes de fréquence en termes de de
j'allais de régularité c'est un peu
aléatoire et vous avez vu que les
sanctions qui sont infligées sont non
seulement rares puisque je crois qu'il y
en a eu que trois mais en plus elles
sont pas tellement dissuasives quand on
voit les bénéfices d'un certain nombre
de grands labos c'est pas ça qui va les
faire
changer de
politique donc nous on dit qu'il faut
donner des moyens à l'Agence nationale
de sécurité du médicament pour que les
contrôles soient plus régulier
et que il puisse y avoir donc des
sanctions qui soient réellement
dissuasives et puis avec aussi une autre
proposition c'est que parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand un laboratoire est
sanctionné
c'est dit
au niveau du site de l'agence à ce
qu'elle
je vais y arriver c'est dit par l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament mais
en fait ça reste un mois sur le site
donc 1 il faut que vous soyez drôlement
averti qui a eu sanction sur le
laboratoire et de faut que vous avez une
fenêtre
d'un mois donc nous pensons que c'est
trop peu et les labos n'aiment pas c'est
cette mesure de dire qu'il faut de la
transparence c'est aussi parce que nous
voulons évidemment qu'un patient qui a
besoin d'un traitement même si il voit
que le labo dont provient son traitement
est sanctionné c'est pas ça qui va le
faire se détourner du labo évidemment
puisqu'il en a besoin c'est un besoin
vital mais c'est pas une bonne pub quand
même pour le labo et donc c'est
important que ça soit sur le site et ça
perdure et pour les contreparts je crois
que tu as répondu sur le cire sur les
contreparties où il faut
toute façon nous nous pensons là encore
c'est à l'aveugle c'est à dire on donne
de oui on donne de l'argent au niveau de
la recherche mais on a bien vu ces
dernières années qu'il y a une politique
de fermeture de sites non seulement de
production mais aussi on se sépare des
chercheurs parce que en fait la
recherche c'est long etc etc et la
stratégie des labos c'est d'acheter les
startups et de pouvoir comme ça il se
débarrasse et après il produisent les
médicaments donc il faut qu'à partir du
moment où on donne où ce sont des fonds
publics qui alimentent cette recherche
il faut qu'il y ait un retour sur
investissement si je puis dire et que le
laboratoire n'est pas la capacité de de
fermer des des sites ou de licencier
sans que on ne lui demande rien il y a
besoin de résultats puisque il y a eu un
investissement des fonds des fonds
publics
sur le sur le crédit d'impôt recherche
dire aussi que on est beaucoup sur
l'innovation thérapeutique mais
l'innovation ce n'est pas que de ce ne
sont pas que des nouveaux médicaments
c'est aussi de nouvelles formes
galéniques et ça ça fait partie de
l'innovation thérapeutique même si c'est
pas l'accès sur le marché à des nouveaux
principes actifs ou des nouveaux
biomédicament et c'est aussi
l'innovation en matière de process de
fabrication parce que plus on est
vertueux sur le plan environnemental par
exemple avec des nouveaux process de
fabrication on peut aussi considérer
qu'on est dans l'innovation et très
clairement ces sujets là doivent être
quand même rééquilibrés dans la mesure
où sa garantit aussi quelque part une
production qui se maintient sur le
territoire français ou à tout et donc on
a besoin un des sujets de de
l'accompagnement public c'est que la
condition de la destination de la
production n'est pas une condition
même en cas de crise c'est-à-dire que ce
qui est produit c'est pas forcément
garantir un accès en France d'ailleurs
c'est ce que le président de la
République a précisé dans les ailes sauf
que maintenant le précise maintenant
sauf que ça fait longtemps qu'on aide et
le crédit bien pour recherche par
exemple dans l'accompagnement des
laboratoires Faber pharmaceutiques c'est
pas un sujet tout à fait récent donc il
y a besoin d'avoir un oeil objectif
pragmatique sur ce sujet c'est à dire
que c'est un accompagnement substantiel
les laboratoires eux-mêmes disent que
c'est un c'est vraiment un facteur
d'attractivité de la France ce crédit
d'impôt recherche et donc la
contrepartie en tout cas dans la
situation sanitaire actuelle des
pénuries qui prennent quand même un
tournant un peu un tour un peu
dramatique pour certains principes
actifs et centres médicament et bien ce
sujet là doit être traité c'est-à-dire
on accompagne on est attractif certes
mais il y a des conditions derrière et
notamment pouvoir créer les conditions
de la production et de la destination
d'une partie de la production
y compris où j'allais dire surtout mais
pas que en cas de crise et de dépendance
sanitaire aiguë
et en fait on a un peu l'esprit
d'escalier et puis on a on a beaucoup
travaillé sur le sur le rapport mais
c'est toujours sur le CIR c'est à dire
qu'à partir du moment où il y a des
recherches qui sont menées et qu'il y a
donc des découvertes il faut aussi qu'il
y ait une garantie
d'approvisionnement du de la France
derrière il y a un certain nombre de
conditionnalités comme celle-ci alors je
vous ai dit qu'on n'avait pas la liste
des 700 mais en fait on a vous pouvez
vous référer pas 106 et 107 non 106
exclusivement où vous allez voir les
produits qui ont déjà été abandonnés
donc c'est important aussi dans notre
appât on ne peut pas vous donner la
liste de ceux qui vont être abandonnés
puisque on n'a pas les noms on a que le
chiffrage mais vous avez pas de 106
ceux qui ont été abandonnés
donc j'ai une question
en distancielle de Rozen le saint
Mediapart
je voulais vous demander comment vous
vous positionnez concernant la
proposition de création d'un pôle public
du médicament qui est différente d'un
recours supplémentaire à la pharmacie
centrale de la PHP que vous mentionnez
et puis en complément je voulais en
savoir un petit peu plus sur les
difficultés que vous avez rencontrées à
obtenir des difficultés des informations
de la part
de Bercy concernant l'utilisation du
cirque et puis des aides à la
relocalisation
merci une autre question
non
vous êtes excusez-moi
sur l'établissement de la liste des
médicaments ce qui existait en matière
de MITM je vois que c'est les
industriels eux-mêmes qui définissaient
la catégorie MITM mais je vois aussi que
vous que tous les MITM devaient faire un
objet d'un stock de deux mois il me
semblait que c'était une proportion plus
restreinte que ça parce que les MITM
représente plusieurs centaines voire
milliers de médicaments donc
voilà j'aurais aimé avoir un point là
dessus sachant qu'effectivement ça pose
aujourd'hui problème avec la liste des
médicaments essentiels qui a été publiés
par le ministère
c'est
bon tu réponds
donc alors sur le pôle public du
médicament je pense que merci de poser
cette question parce que ça vous a pas
échappé
c'est un vrai sujet et
mon groupe en 2020 le 9 décembre à
déposé une proposition de loi qui a été
examinée
au Sénat et qui a proposé un pôle public
du médicament et des dispositifs
médicaux malheureusement c'est moi qui
parle en tant que voilà personnellement
je trouve que c'est dommage que cette
proposition de loi n'est pas été adoptée
à l'époque mais j'attire votre attention
sur le fait qu'il me semble qu'il y a
quand même des petits bougies entre le
moment où cette proposition de loi passe
au Sénat
et donc il y a ce vote et aujourd'hui
vous avez quand même entendu la tonalité
et vous allez lire le rapport vous allez
voir que les choses ont
évolué le rapport a été a été voté
il y a aucune voix contre et
on a insisté sur le fait de parce qu'il
y a un moment donné il faut quand même
se rendre compte que il y a une faillite
de la politique du médicament à partir
du moment où on voit toutes ces pénuries
où on voit une envolée
gigantesque de prix des traitements
innovants où on a le sentiment que il y
a pas de contre-pouvoir face à cette
conception du marché c'est à dire
effectivement le médicament dans notre
société est considéré comme une
marchandise et nous nous disons NON et
nous quand je dis nous heureusement
c'est pas seulement
la présidente et moi c'est bien au-delà
nous disons le médicament doit être
retiré de cette conception marchande
c'est un bien universel et à partir du
moment où on considère que c'est un bien
universel un bien commun de l'humanité
on doit en tirer des conséquences et on
doit donner des pouvoirs à la puissance
publique pour
pouvoir produire et distribuer des
médicaments or si vous voulez on a vu
tout au cours de nos auditions que
lajeps qui avait des possibilités il y a
quelques années encore de produire des
médicaments pour
notamment l'APHP petit à petit on l'a
désarmé dire que non seulement il y a
pas la possibilité de quelque part de
pouvoir faire face mais en plus cette
c'est un agence cette pharmacie centrale
a eu des des moyens qui ont été à
moindris donc nous disons il faut cesser
ça d'autant que si vous voulez
là encore il faut tirer des
enseignements de la covid tirer des
enseignements de la covid on a vu que du
coup on a donné notamment à la GEPS des
possibilités c'est grâce à la GEPS et
avec ses partenaires de pouvoir produire
du curare qui était qui était manquant
et qui était essentiel par rapport aux
patients et là on sait pas embarrassé de
savoir est-ce que ils peuvent ils
peuvent pas est-ce que les règlements le
permettent ou pas c'était urgent c'est
urgence c'est pareil pour les
préparations hospitalières ou le
préparations d'officine etc donc nous
nous disons puisque c'est possible en
cas d'urgence et puisque tout le monde
considère que c'est positif et ben
donnons-nous les moyens par rapport à
une liste restreinte d'une cinquantaine
de médicaments et bien de pouvoir donner
à la gepse la possibilité de faire cette
cette production et donc de y compris
petit à petit de se développer et de
voir comment c'est possible avec des
avec des des comment s'appelle des
sous-traitants avec etc etc tout un
réseau mais qui se passe sous contrôle
public ça c'est extrêmement extrêmement
important donc voilà c'est là où on nous
en sommes au niveau de notre de notre
rapport moi je pense que c'est un petit
pack a été franchi ou petite fenêtre qui
s'est ouverte maintenant faut voir
comment le le gouvernement peut peut
s'en emparer veut s'en emparer ou pas
voilà sur les stocks vous savez il y a
la plupart donc
des médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeurs sont sur le statut de deux mois
et il y en a quelques-uns qui sont sur
quatre mois
ce qu'il faut savoir et nous le
soulignons également dans notre rapport
c'est que nous nous avions souhaité au
niveau du Sénat il y a eu un vote
d'ailleurs où nous avions demandé que
les stocks soient quatre mois
malheureusement alors que ça avait été
voté malheureusement ça n'a pas été
conservé
de MITM au final parce que on s'y perd
en fait on a 6000 6000 donc
justement c'est cette question de
l'ambiguïté de la diversité d'eliste
entre les fameux MTM les nouveaux MCI
les les médicaments diessentiels à
risque critique c'est-à-dire à risque de
pénurie important enfin on se retrouve
avec des listes constituées dans tous
les sens et en réalité l'important c'est
d'avoir sur quelle lisse on a soit une
réaction
sous pilotage public en cas de besoin
parce que la pénurie met en danger la
sécurité sanitaire parce que c'est ça le
sujet enfin la sécurité sanitaire c'est
à dire que la carence du médicament en
question a un impact sanitaire qui est
une réelle perte de chance et donc le
sujet le sujet il est vraiment là et
donc on cherche pas à voir 15 listes ce
qu'il faut c'est que tout le monde se
mette d'accord et d'ailleurs c'est le
travail de l'Agence européenne du
médicament c'est pour ça qu'on s'y est
déplacé puisque c'est là que
à Alma une des missions en matière de
pénurie c'est de constituer cette
fameuse liste donc de toute façon la
question européenne elle va se poser sur
ce sujet parce qu'on va on va évidemment
chaque pays dans le cadre de la
supériarité des politiques publiques en
matière sanitaires va avoir sa propre
liste mais sans être complètement
j'allais dire délirant au rêveur il va
bien y avoir des points de convergence
entre tous les pays sur ces sur les
listes et il faut il faudra bien
évidemment se mettre d'accord aussi pour
utiliser le levier supplémentaire qui
est le levier européen puisque
évidemment l'effet volume de la
consommation de médicaments est un
élément d'arbitrage important de la part
des laboratoires pour produire et pour
distribuer donc il est voilà important
que je dois les deux de jouer aux deux
échelles mais cette fameuse liste elle
est elle est importante parce que c'est
pas parce qu'on a une pénurie récurrente
qu'on est forcément en difficulté pour
de pouvoir accéder aux médicaments des
fois c'est pour plein de raisons c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas assez finalement de
laboratoire qui produit ce médicament
qui interviennent sur le marché français
etc etc il y a la question du prix qui
intervient mais mais clairement on a
besoin de vraiment identifier ces
médicaments qui mettent en difficulté
sur le plan sanitaire le pays je
voudrais ajouter un truc sur le quelque
chose qui est quand même qui nous a
semblé assez important et qu'on souligne
dans dans le rapport c'est que
l'estimation du coût du coup en euros
sonore est trébuchant mais du coup
sanitaire aussi de la pénurie des
médicaments n'est pas n'est pas n'est
pas produit c'est à dire ce coup là on
ne le connaît pas or ce coup là et bien
il a un impact sur Honda sur le PLFSS
sur la dépense médicament que c'est une
question qu'on a posée de façon
récurrente aux instances sanitaires et
en charge du sujet et on a pas eu de
réponse et quand au sanitaire il a aussi
un coup en matière budgétaire évidemment
parce que le renoncement au traitement
le remplacement par un médicament
équivalent mais pour lesquels on n'a pas
forcément toujours la même réaction on
parle le phénomène allergique on parle
de moins bonne prise en charge c'est
pour ce qu'on appelle les traitements
chroniques c'est-à-dire on a son même
médicament et puis du jour au lendemain
il est remplacé par un autre qui est
équivalent mais qui a pas forcément la
même pharmacocinétique parce qu'ils sont
pas les mêmes exceptions etc voilà donc
ce sujet là c'est un sujet important
parce que ça peut être un risque
évidemment de déstabilisation de la
prise en charge thérapeutique sur des
maladies chroniques donc il y a le
renoncement le il y a le retard aussi
c'est à dire qu'il y a un certain nombre
de patients mais qui attendent 15 jours
voire plus un pour certains traitements
notamment des anticancériques pour avoir
pour avoir accès au traitement et donc
c'est et puis le coup sanitaire c'est
aussi tout ce que
c'est tout le temps passé au niveau des
pharmacies au niveau des médecins de la
prise en charge médicale pour régler
cette question des pénuries qui est une
question non négligeable et sur le coup
réel
on sait que quand il y a une un
contingentement et puis oui sur le coup
sanitaire il y a les contingentements
parce qu'on parle des pénuries mais
enfin un contingentement c'est quoi dans
les faits c'est 100 personnes malades le
médicament disponible pour 5 ans ça veut
dire que pour 50 c'est une pénurie c'est
ça la réalité du contingentement c'est
un peu trivial comme comme mais c'est ça
ça veut dire que quand même ce sont des
pénuries partielles contingentement
c'est le terme un peu qui est utilisé
légalement ça fait moins peur mais enfin
c'est une pénurie partielle de
contingentement donc ça aussi ça a un
coût un coup sanitaire réel et quand au
coup au budgétaire souvent le médicament
emplacement est plus cher c'est assez
régulier on sait que quand il y a une
pénurie hospitalière on renégocié avec
un autre laboratoire souvent le coût est
plus important et donc il y a tout un
tas de de sujets aussi du point de vue
de la dépense en matière de médicaments
tout ça devrait être évalué estimé me
semble-t-il puisque c'est un outil de
pilotage budgétaire aussi de la dépense
publique en matière sanitaire
pour répondre sur la question des
difficultés d'accès à l'information
à Bercy
il y a eu plusieurs il y a eu un
courrier bon
pas raconter les histoires de chasse
mais il s'est perdu bon on a donc
relancé on a eu
un rendez-vous
[Musique]
voilà pas très tôt mais on en a eu quand
même et quand on est arrivé il y avait
pas
de pièces il y avait des gens mais pas
de pièces dans la pièce et donc on a eu
on a eu finalement une liasse
oui on peut dire ça une liasse qui nous
est parvenue
je sais pas plus tard
pas dans les délais sur lesquels on nous
avait dit qu'ils arriveraient mais et
donc une liasse
issue de Bercy sans avoir le décodeur
c'est pas toujours un truc super simple
à gérer mais évidemment le Sénat est en
plein de ressources et tout le monde est
en plein de compétences on a réussi à
l'utiliser mais ça signifie quand même
qu'on a un petit sujet de transparence
parce que il devrait être possible tous
les ans de faire le bilan
du crédit d'impôt recherche
secteur d'industrie par secteur
d'industrie et notamment l'industrie
pharmaceutique est quand même le
deuxième en matière d'accompagnement le
second pour
cette industrie là devrait faire l'objet
d'un comment dire d'un bilan à tout le
monde enfin je pense que ce bilan là
simple pourquoi quel type de thérapie
quel type d'accompagnement enfin tous
ces sujets là la somme ne serait-ce que
la somme enfin en fonction de la
typologie de d'entreprise etc c'est un
sujet que je pense que le crédit d'impro
recherche parce qu'il a un facteur
d'attractivité doit justement être
particulièrement suivi parce que on peut
même le rendre plus efficace encore
puisque c'est un facteur d'attractivité
et donc c'est pas forcément pour le
brider mais pour lui rendre plus
d'efficacité en matière de politique
sanitaire
et puisque ce que je voulais on va y
arriver on a des petits papiers c'est
génial ce que je voulais aussi ajouter
c'est que ça a été quand même très
troublant quand on vous dit que il y a
un espèce de travail en silo c'est quand
on arrive à Bercy on avait l'impression
que les les questions que nous posions
ne rentrait pas dans les dans les cases
des tableaux Excel et
c'était à se dire que bon alors
finalement si on veut avoir
immédiatement une information
un moment donné où on est en 2023 où
l'informatique c'est génial on peut
quand même croiser des têtes de données
là visiblement c'était extrêmement
compliqué alors bon ils nous ont demandé
un délai on leur a donné le délai ils
ont dépassé le délai
et
pour arriver à savoir que c'était 710
millions qui étaient donnés il a fallu
quand même
comment voulez-vous
établir
une décision politique et des décisions
fortes quand vous mettez autant de temps
à recueillir les informations même si on
peut admettre que peut-être que au
niveau du gouvernement ça va plus vite
en tout cas j'ose espérer mais là ça a
l'air ça a l'air très compliqué et il
faut savoir aussi que outre ce que ce
qu'a dit Sonia
la présidence c'est que le SIR donc 710
millions qui sont distribués comme ça
sans vraiment de bilan
et l'industrie pharmaceutique donc très
bien placé Sanofi étant en premier
j'attire quand même votre attention par
rapport à toutes les annonces qu'on
entend de de fermeture etc ça c'est la
c'est ce que je voulais je voulais vous
dire et l'autre chose c'est parce que ça
me paraît important très rapidement
c'est sûr les les effets que peuvent
avoir les pénuries sur les patientes et
les patients et notamment je veux
attirer votre attention sur les
traitements de substitution parce que
bon quand on n'est pas dans le monde
médical on peut se dire bon bah après il
y a certains traitements où il y a pas
de substitution donc ça voilà je vais
pas aborder mais il y a des traitements
ou effectivement on peut trouver
d'autres traitements de substitution et
là moi j'ai été très attentive à cet
élément parce que ça n'est pas si
évident que ça parce que ça n'est pas si
évident que ça parce que les effets
secondaires ne sont pas les mêmes et
parce que il extrêmement compliqué
d'équilibrer les traitements c'est à
dire que quand on donne un nouveau
traitement et bien c'est pas c'est pas
mathématique et voilà on donne et puis
c'est bon il faut trouver un
équilibrage qui fait que ça prend du
temps et les patients peuvent être
en difficulté en souffrance ça je
voulais insister et je voulais attirer
votre attention parce que je pense
notamment aux patients qui souffrent
d'épilepsie et là c'est extrêmement
extrêmement compliqué
oui puis pour compléter la pilule
laportive par exemple on n'a pas voilà
on n'a pas d'alternative pour pour la
pilule abortive les entités épileptiques
tu as tout à fait raison c'était on sait
à quel point c'est compliqué de régler
un accompagnement thérapeutique
chronique en matière d'épilepsie et tout
élément perturbant cette prise en charge
thérapeutique est un élément de
déstabilisation et peut être un facteur
de risque de retour des crises et on a
bien vu et puis aussi il y a la question
de la forme galénique c'est à dire que
les corticoïdes en gouttes qui font
défaut tous les hivers au moment de
l'épidémie de bronchiolite alors que
l'épidémie de bronchiolite touche les
nourrissons et que évidemment ils ne
peuvent pas prendre des corticoïdes
autrement que sous une forme liquide
c'est quand même un sujet c'est-à-dire
que on a aussi la disponibilité du
médicament mais la forme galénique est
aussi un élément important c'est-à-dire
que la question de la pénurie c'est
vraiment c'est tous ces sujets là qu'il
faut traiter c'est pas que en fait ce
qui depuis plusieurs années avait été le
l'espèce de sujet comme ça ça nous
permettait de repousser ça un peu aux
portes de nos frontières quelque part la
question de la dépendance à l'un des
machines en matière de principe actif
c'est une réalité bien sûr mais il y a
pas que ça il y a plein de sujets
derrière et notamment en matière de
cortico de corticoïdes
l'usine euro happy nous a bien confirmé
puisqu'on s'est déplacé que les
corticoïdes les principes actifs étaient
fabriqués en France pour un grand nombre
que ça faisait partie de leur production
et qu'ils étaient pas au maximum de la
production qu'il pouvait proposer donc
c'est bien toute la chaîne qu'il faut
regarder derrière et arrêter de dire
systématiquement que c'est uniquement la
question des principes actifs il y a une
logique de dispo de mise en
disponibilité du médicament sur le
territoire qui en fait dépend de chaque
élément de la chaîne de valeur du du
médicament
il y a deux questions
en visio
[Musique]
donc Madame Mélanie Mazières pour le
Quotidien du Pharmacien
bonjour Est-ce que vous m'entendez oui
on vous entend oui merci bonjour je
voulais revenir sur la problématique du
désarmement de l'ajeps que vous avez
déjà évoqué vous avez vous l'avez mis en
évidence lors de l'audition la dernière
audition du ministre de la Santé qui
semblait un peu découvrir le sujet et
qui avait dit qu'il reviendrait vers
vous pour répondre à vos questions je
voudrais savoir si ça a été le cas s'il
est bien revenu vers vous et si oui
quelles sont les réponses qu'il vous a
donné merci
et puis la tribune de l'assurance
oui je voudrais revenir sur la
relocalisations
vous avez dit que en effet 18 projets de
relocalisation était
activée dont cinq seulement sur le
relatif à des principes actifs
stratégiques trois ans après la pandémie
quel est votre vous êtes critique par
rapport à cette stratégie de
relocalisation mais est-ce que vous avez
réussi à identifier les raisons pour
lesquelles la stratégie de requalisation
sur la filière
pharmaceutique qui est quand même très
très limitée
alors c'est sur sur le
ministre qui était étonné qui semblait
découvrir effectivement ces suppressions
programmées à la jette il devait revenir
vers nous il n'est pas revenu vers nous
donc là ma réponse est est rapide et
mais par contre effectivement
comme je l'ai dit au début de mon propos
nous allons nous allons demander une
rencontre et évidemment à ce propos nous
allons réitérer notre notre
questionnement ensuite c'était sur voilà
moi je vous je sais pas si vous avez de
devant vous vous avez le rapport vous
avez aussi l'essentiel et à l'essentiel
je suis désolé vous avez pas 10 et page
10 là on voit on voit très bien
tout ce qui concerne les relocalisations
grâce à des aides qui sont ciblées etc
et je pense que là on a
on a vraiment les différentes les
différentes étapes et le fait que il y a
une nécessité vraiment de suivi
c'est-à-dire que pour l'instant il y a
je dirais une prise de conscience il
semblerait qu'il y ait une prise de
conscience du gouvernement disant il
faut une relocalisation mais nous avons
vu que les annonces ne sont pas
suffisantes et qui compris quand on
parle de relocalisation il faut bien
réfléchir au relocalisation c'est au
niveau de toutes les étapes c'est à dire
du début du principe actif jusque à la
production du médicament de la petite
gélule ou etc or parfois
souvent même je dirais et bien quand il
y a relocalisation ça va pas être du
début de la chaîne à la fin de la chaîne
donc il faut y être extrêmement attentif
on n'a pas la prétention ni l'idée ni ce
serait complètement absurde de dire il
faut tout relocaliser en France
c'est impossible c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que nous avons parlé
notamment dans notre rapport et nous
l'avons dit dans nos propos introductifs
qu'il faut une coopération plus grande
au niveau de l'Europe c'est quand même
différent si vous voulez la difficulté
c'est qu'on vous a dit que 80 % des
principes actifs aujourd'hui et se
retrouver en Chine ou en Asie etc enfin
donc c'est où en Inde donc bon c'est
vrai que là c'est ça pose problème donc
il faut faire en sorte que ça puisse se
trouver en France et que ça puisse se
trouver aussi au niveau au niveau de
l'Europe avec et je le je le souligne
encore des une prise en compte de ce que
ça veut dire parce que quand depuis 30
ans les entreprises délocalisent elles
délocalise pour une plus grande
rentabilité parce qu'elles vont se
retrouver dans des pays avec des
exigences sociales et environnementales
qui sont moindres
si on demande à ces entreprises de
revenir il faut prendre en compte le
fait que elles vont elles vont respecter
des normes environnementales et sociales
plus exigeante et donc il faut aussi
prendre en compte ces éléments-là dans
la fixation après du prix et puis il
faut aussi interroger l'ensemble de la
société sur la place de l'industrie
chimique parce que aujourd'hui quand on
veut quand on dit il faut relocaliser
tout le monde dit oui il faut
relocaliser on a besoin des médicaments
à juste titre etc mais comme l'industrie
chimique est particulièrement polluante
tout le monde dit d'accord mais pas chez
nous
donc là il faut se mettre on est sur du
ceriseau plus et à partir de cette prise
de conscience il faut qu'il y ait
effectivement un travail qui soit fait
d'information et aussi de prise en
compte de l'évolution des techniques
parce que aujourd'hui il y a des
possibilités qui sont beaucoup plus
importantes qu'il y a 30 ans pour par
rapport à l'eau par rapport à l'air etc
mais ça nécessite des investissements
effectivement important de la part de la
part des industriels
voilà et la PHP a fait deux offres de
services 2022 et 2023 pour façonner à
nouveau
une formation
oui oui l'industrie chimique est classé
en France ces vaisseaux seuil haut donc
évidemment avec tout ce que ça comporte
voilà de d'angoisse pour pour les
communes donc c'est un un des sujets
bien évidemment en matière de
relocalisation il y a aussi un
sujet c'est à dire que
la relocalisation c'est assurer la
production d'un médicament dit essentiel
ou en tout cas dans une situation de
critique importante pour des raisons de
monopoles et de fragilité de fabrication
à l'extérieur de nos frontières y
compris des frontières européennes
et donc c'est vraiment on est vraiment
sur des médicaments plutôt matures c'est
aussi se poser la question des pénuries
de demain c'est-à-dire sur des
médicaments innovants mais dont on sait
dès à présent qui vont être faire partie
de de la prise en charge thérapeutique
j'allais dire classique voilà et qui
seront finalement les médicaments
matures de demain mais de demain assez
vite parce que dans dans 10 ans un
certain nombre de thérapies très dite
très innovantes maintenant vont
rapidement rentrer dans des process qui
vont être de de prise en charge
classique d'un certain nombre de
traitements donc ça ça sente ici pour le
coup là on a le temps c'est à dire que
la question du temps de
construction des usines et
de la mise en place du process
industriel ce temps-là on l'a donc il
faut le faire dire ça sente ici et puis
c'est aussi la production de de c'est la
question de tout ce qui est thérapie
très innovante et là on est vraiment
dans l'innovation pure on n'est pas au
stade on est parfois Costa de la
recherche fondamentale on est parfois
déjà dans la brique au dessus et au
stade de de la recherche appliquée et
donc ça aussi ça doit s'accompagner et
et donc en fait dans l'accompagnement du
médicament l'accompagnement public
financier du médicament il y a ces trois
sujets qui doivent être gardés et des
gars importantes des gars importantes
parce qu'en une fois c'est pas parce
qu'un médicament est mature qui les daté
sur le plan thérapeutique voilà et donc
c'est vraiment ça le sujet et on ne
saurait s'exonéré de se poser la
question de qu'est-ce qu'on doit
maintenir et puis pour la question de la
difficulté finalement liée à la fois la
destrie chimique ou alors au risque
inhérents à à toutes ces questions là je
veux dire l'innovation c'est aussi un
sujet c'est à dire l'innovation dans le
process de fabrication c'est quand même
un élément de sécurisation au sens
primum du terme de la fabrication du
médicament c'est dans sécurisation sur
plan environnemental
et vis-à-vis du risque ces vaisseaux
ce qu'il y a d'autres questions oui
oui bonjour Zélia j'ai fait un du monde
simplement vous avez dit que vous avez
demandé un rendez-vous au ministère
au ministre de la Santé au ministre de
l'Industrie vous faites beaucoup de
recommandations un constat critique
parmi toutes ces recommandations
lesquelles vous avez envie de porter
lesquels sont les plus urgentes à mettre
en place il y en avait quelques-unes
vraiment à retenir principalement
ma question recoupe celle de ma conso
parce que je voulais vous demander
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être repris dans
le projet loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale et vous disiez en tout
début de
d'intervention que la communication du
ministère du ministre de la Santé a été
particulièrement brouillé est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer un petit peu
ce que vous entendez par là s'il vous
plaît
si vous voulez je vais commencer par par
votre question c'est ça a été
particulièrement brouillé parce qu'il y
a eu des il y a eu des informations
contradictoires c'est-à-dire que en fait
on voit bien que on a eu le sentiment
quand même que on est plus justement
dans des dans des éléments de com
sans prendre le temps d'avoir une
véritable
information on va dire aux patientes et
aux patients on a eu le sentiment y
compris d'ailleurs nous l'avons souligné
durant notre notre commission qui avait
un peu une course contre la menthe
c'est-à-dire que vous avez certainement
ça ne vous a pas échappé que pendant
tout pratiquement tout le temps de la
commission d'enquête il y a eu des
annonces du ministère on avait
l'impression qu'ils nous courait après
pardonnez-moi l'expression mais c'était
un peu ça on parlait de la nécessité de
restreint de faire une liste restreinte
etc PAF il y avait une annonce de jour
après enfin ça a été pratiquement de
manière presque constante
la
stratégie
gouvernementale alors que nous il nous
semblait que dans une situation où
vraiment écouter là on est on est
plusieurs réunis en tout cas nous avons
chacun chacune un exemple ou de
quelqu'un d'un membre de notre famille
ou de nous-même ou d'un voisin qui
souffre d'une difficulté pour pouvoir
trouver le traitement qui lui est
nécessaire donc on est vraiment dans une
situation extrêmement tendue d'urgence à
partir de là je pense qu'il faut au
contraire qu'on coordonne nos efforts et
qu'on travaille ensemble et pas en
rivalité à celui qui va sortir le
premier or on a un peu là on a un peu ce
sentiment là et effectivement votre
concert de libération l'a dit au niveau
de la liste des médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur alors là il y a eu
tout et son contraire donc à un moment
donné si vous voulez ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas vraiment
de nature à apaiser les angoisses
justifiés des patientes et et des
patients c'est en cela que l'on parle
que l'on parle d'une d'une information
d'une information brouillée et puis vous
avez pour trouver les les informations
réelles c'est extrêmement compliqué par
exemple moi j'insiste à nouveau sur la
pilule abortive par exemple le ministre
de la Santé dit il y a pas de pénurie
nous nous sommes alertés par des
associations notamment par le planning
familial mais pas que qui nous dit qui
nous dit on ne peut pas les femmes ne
peuvent pas avoir de un accès à cette
pilule abortive dans plusieurs régions
sauf que et c'est pour ça qu'on insiste
dans notre rapport sur la notion de
proximité c'est à dire et le lien qui
doit y avoir entre l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament et les ARS pour
être au plus près du terrain parce que
il peut on peut dire au plan national
il y a pas spécialement de pénurie
mais dans tel ou telle région il peut y
avoir absence
de cette pilule et la personne ne va pas
pouvoir quand vous avez décidé de faire
une interruption volontaire de grossesse
vous allez pas dire bon voilà je suis à
Paris mais je sais par exemple qu'à
Strasbourg ou que ou que à Nice elle est
disponible c'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne donc là on voit bien qu'il y
a quelque chose qui ne qui ne va pas et
pour pour ce que nous en avons vu nous
avons auditionné
l'entreprise donc dont j'ai oublié le
nom qui qui donc fabriqué ces pilules
voilà nordique farm c'est intéressant
que j'ai oublié le nom c'est marrant
enfin bon donc quand on les a
auditionnés je vous je vous invite à
regarder leur audition parce que toute
façon tout reste sur le site il y a même
un compte rendu et vous verrez que il y
a aucun problème
donc vous avez
l'entreprise qui dit il y a aucun
problème et vous avez les femmes qui
nous alertent en disant mais nous on n'a
pas accès à cette pilule donc voilà
voilà ce que et le ministère qui dit non
non mais il y a pas tout va bien ou
alors qui dit bah vous inquiétez pas
comme il l'a dit d'ailleurs pour pour
les antibiotiques donc un jour c'est
mieux et puis on s'aperçoit donc un jour
ça va pas mieux donc ça ne crée pas des
liens de confiance donc ça c'est ce que
je voulais je moi je voulais souligner
la deuxième deuxième chose la deuxième
question Quels sont les mesures sur les
36 mesures qui qui nous apparaissent
enfin qui là ça va être très personnel
en réalité parce que elles sont toutes
elles sont toutes très importantes en ce
sens où vraiment elles prennent en
compte la chaîne du médicament du début
jusqu'à la fin donc elles ont toute une
logique elles sont toutes extrêmement
importantes
ceci dit moi ce que je je trouve qu'il
faudrait certainement en tout cas mettre
en avant et s'y atteler très vite c'est
la conditionnalité des aides publiques
ça je pense que ça c'est un élément
extrêmement important on ne peut pas
donner des aides publiques sans avoir de
bilan et de bilan dans la transparence
et conditionner les aides publiques au
service rendu les industries
pharmaceutiques doivent être
traités comme toute comme tout à chacun
donc à partir du moment où il y a des
fonds publics il doit y avoir un service
rendu donc conditionnalités
renforcement
des des moyens qui sont alloués pour
qu'il y ait des contrôles pour que les
plantes gestion de pénurie
soit
soit de bon niveau parce que nous avons
pu constater puisque les plans de les
PGP nous sont nous sont parvenus que
c'est extrêmement inégal
que c'est pour certains très mal
renseignés et que
finalement
on sent contente donc il faut avoir une
exigence là aussi à partir du moment où
on se dote de dispositif qui peuvent
être performants et qui sont importants
il faut qu'il y ait un contrôle et que
on demande à ce que la copie elle soit
revue dans l'intérêt évidemment de
satisfaire les besoins en matière de
santé des patientes et des patients donc
conditionnalités des aides
contrôle renforcé et puis
je pense que il faut mettre en oeuvre
rapidement le fait qu'il y ait une une
maîtrise et une fabrication publique
d'un certain nombre de médicaments sous
le la houlette j'allais dire de la GEPS
avec un
des moyens qui lui soit restitués et la
possibilité effectivement de revoir les
réglementations qui l'empêchent de
d'avoir un certain nombre d'initiatives
hors période hors période de crise et
enfin que
il y ait une autre organisation au
niveau du médicament qui permette de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait un pilote
dans l'avion c'est-à-dire là vous avez
une multiplicité une multiplicité des
agences elles font toutes un travail
remarquable mais à un moment donné moi
j'insiste et je suis convaincu la
décision elle doit être prise
politiquement le pilote doit être
politique et c'est lui qui doit décider
comme visiblement là ça ne se fait pas
donc c'est pour ça que nous avons parlé
d'un secrétariat et enfin toute dernière
chose quand même c'est sur le les prix
des médicaments je pense que là aussi il
faut revoir les choses
et que en tout cas il faut une grande
transparence et il faut que la
composition du CEPS soit revue soit avec
un renforcement des acteurs et des
actrices du monde médical que ce soit
les professionnels de santé ou que ce
soit les usagers ou que ce soit
je crois que j'ai fait le tour c'est bon
voilà
sur la communication dans dans le
rapport et dans l'essentiel page 8 on
explique par exemple la question de la
communication
itérative sur la disponibilité en
matière d'amoxicilline et par cet amole
ou enfin surtout l'amoxicilline
d'ailleurs donc on a bien vu
qu'évidemment ça se fait pas au doigt
mouillé en décrète pas que ça va revenir
en France comme ça quoi et c'est
d'ailleurs une part de la réponse à la
question qui nous a été faite
c'est-à-dire que on le rapport est épais
les propositions nombreuses parce que en
réalité à trop vouloir traiter une
question disant celle-là est prioritaire
sur les autres finalement on n'a pas
traité grand chose ces dernières années
et donc c'est quand même un sujet c'est
à dire que c'est complexe oui assumons
le fait que ce soit complexe la chaîne
de valeur du médicament que ce soit
multifactorielle assumons aussi le fait
qu'il y a des situations structurelles
et des situations conjoncturelles et que
donc les solutions sont pas exactement
de même nature notamment en matière de
pilotage politique parce que quand il y
a une crise il faut pouvoir répondre
politiquement je veux dire il faut un et
là pour l'instant on l'a pas et une
crise ça peut être une pénurie d'un
médicament majeur
immédiatement donc ça c'est ça fait
quand même partie des sujets qu'on
devrait pouvoir traiter politiquement
avec une candidature et aussi un
pilotage public sur un système de veille
qui est suffisamment outillé et
constitué dans les territoires pour que
le va et vient entre le National et le
local se fasse parce que en fait le
discours de discours du ministre un
discours sur l'état national et donc
c'est ce qui vient d'être expliqué très
très précisément par par Madame la
rapporteur et donc c'est vraiment un
sujet et puis enfin dire quand même que
nous annoncer une liste de 58 la veille
de l'audition et direction générale aux
entreprises par la fameuse direction en
question avec comment dire des réponses
lacunaire ou lunaire je sais pas si on
prend toutes les syllabes sur sur la
constitution de cette liste c'est quand
même un sujet quoi on s'en fiche qui est
Nice de 58 ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il est
la bonne liste au bon moment qui est de
la transparence sur la constitution sur
quels critères on l'a fait enfin voilà
et le process quoi qui intervient enfin
c'est ça surtout le sujet quoi que ce
soit dans le rapport du Sénat ou que ce
soit à la main la direction générale aux
entreprises c'est pas vraiment le sujet
au bout du compte de tout ça il y a
quand même des patients des patients et
voilà des gens qui sont concernés par
par le sujet en direct il y a des
prescripteurs il y a des dispensateurs
et puis il y a aussi ceux qui fabriquent
et donc voilà c'est un sujet
suffisamment important pour éviter des
communications qui sont
erratiques et pas toujours à la hauteur
des attentes et la fameuse liste des 450
montre à quel point c'est quand même
dommageable sur un sujet aussi essentiel
que cette liste qui est quand même la
clé de la réaction en matière d'urgence
en matière de pénurie c'est quand même
dommageable que la communication
se soit faite de cette façon avec à la
fois des doutes et et en tâchant
finalement quelque part la qualité et
l'utilité de cette liste alors donc
alors qu'on sait y compris au niveau
européen et dans plein de pays en dehors
de l'Europe que cette liste elle est
quand même très utile pour avoir une
vision pragmatique éclaire de la façon
dont on remet à disposition le plus vite
possible des médicaments qui sont en
situation de pénurie
qu'on a répondu à toutes les questions
[Musique]
oui allez-y juste sur la régulation du
prix du médicament ça doit se faire dans
le prochain PLFSS selon vous
en fait il y a un certain nombre
d'éléments qui qui devront être qui
relève du PLFSS il y en a d'autres qui
ne relèvent pas du PLFSS c'est pas une
réponse
normande mais
bon mais en fait oui c'est vrai que par
exemple il y a des moyens à louer à
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament ça ça relève du PLFSS mais il
y a d'autres d'autres
comment dirais-je d'autres éléments qui
ne vont pas relever du PLFSS
il y a beaucoup dans l'organisationnel
enfin dans le dans le process quand même
des visionnelles
dans la transparence dans la
Constitution par exemple de du CEPS et
la sous-représentation de la dimension
sanitaire dans les décisions c'est quand
même un élément important c'est à dire
que voilà oui il peut y avoir une vraie
discussion au moment du PLFSS mais enfin
comment dire ne
cédons pas à l'habitude que nous avons
classiquement c'est à dire c'est de
prendre des décisions avant d'avoir fait
un diagnostic précis des besoins
voilà c'est pas exclu loin de là mais il
faut quand même se poser la question de
toute façon ce qui est mis en évidence
qu'on traite la question hospitalière
qu'on traite la question des dispositifs
médicaux qu'on traite la question de la
médecine de ville qu'on traite la
question du médicament on voit bien que
les objectifs de London sont pas à la
hauteur des besoins et qui a un certain
nombre de sujets à se poser et de
questions à se poser et cette histoire
des vases communicants entre les
différentes enveloppes pour rendre un
nom d'âme et qui enfin PLFSS
qui tiennent qui tiennent la route par
rapport aux objectifs de London c'est
quand même un sujet c'est à dire que si
on retire dans le médicament et bien la
conséquence c'est que ce sont des
médicaments qui sont des remboursés
moins bien remboursés ou pas rembourser
du tout ou alors qui ne sont plus
distribués sur le marché donc tout ça
est lié et que on peut pas considérer
que parce que on prend une partie de la
somme pour mettre sur l'hôpital d'abord
il faut être certain que ça serve à ce
que ça fonctionne moins au niveau
hospitalier en tout cas on peut pas se
ce comment dire sans laver les mains de
des conséquences que ça sur le plan de
la prise en charge thérapeutique
et puis par exemple la clause de
sauvegarde elle elle relève du PLFSS
mais nous on a on a une formule qui est
assez
revoir ou réviser je me souviens plus
comment on a tourné la recommandation au
niveau de la clause de sauvegarde c'est
parce que on a vraiment
en tout cas compris et on souhaiterait
que le gouvernement tire vraiment un
bilan et remettre les choses à plat
parce que si vous touchez un élément de
la clause de sauvegarde c'est comme un
jeu de cartes ça s'effondre donc il faut
vraiment bien mesurer tous les tenants
et les aboutissants quand on demande de
la transparence par exemple et bien le
c'est un président à ce créateur du CEPS
le responsable le président le président
du du CEPS lui nous dit mais attention
parce que en même temps il y a le prix
facial mais il y a les remises qui
accordent les laboratoires et si on rend
public les remises qui accordent les
laboratoires et bien ça va poser
effectivement
problème parce que
ça va tout remettre en cause donc il y a
un certain on peut pas on peut pas
comment faire ça d'un claquement de
doigts c'est pourquoi vraiment on
insiste toutes les deux et le rapport le
portent c'est de dire mais évaluons les
politiques qui sont menées mais allons
jusqu'au bout la clause de sauvegarde au
départ elle n'était pas conçue de cette
façon là et ça n'était pas pour tout les
médicaments matures n'étaient pas dans
la clause de sauvegarde donc les choses
ont évolué est-ce que maintenant ça
correspond bien à la situation
d'aujourd'hui nous en doutons mais il
faut pas prendre une mesure à laver vite
en disant bah on va faire ça non
mesurons bien tout les avantages et les
inconvénients et comment est-ce qu'on
peut faire en sorte malgré tout que
contenu des profits exponentiels des
grands laboratoires il ne passe pas au
travers des mailles du filet et qui
contribuent à à aux besoins des
Françaises et des Français
oui juste une demande de précision sur
le crédit impôt recherche vous dites que
vous avez beaucoup de mal à voir le
chiffre de 710 millions d'euros
quel est le chiffre pour Sanofi qui donc
doit être en tête de cette de ce cire et
la pharmacie c'est le second
bénéficiaire de ce de ce crédit quel est
le premier bénéficiaire quel est le
secteur qui est qui est numéro un
alors
c'est l'aéronautique mais
en fait la relat nous sommes en fait
nous sommes tenus
à au secret je sais pas si c'est secret
des affaires en tout cas on peut pas on
peut pas divulguer c'est à dire on dit
on vous dit le chiffre de 710 millions
d'euros mais on peut pas aller plus loin
dans les détails de combien voilà c'est
très très encadré
ah oui c'est pas le secret des affaires
c'est le secret fiscal
mais si nous n'étions pas soumis à
secret fiscal on aurait partagé
c'est un autre sujet de transparence
il y a plus de c'est bon
je vous remercie beaucoup excusez-moi
oui heureuse est-ce que vous pouvez nous
indiquer si Sanofi est le premier
bénéficiaire du cirque parmi les
entreprises pharmaceutiques ou parmi
toutes les entreprises qui en
bénéficient s'il vous plaît
c'est c'est parmi les entreprises
pharmaceutiques
merci la réponse